[Music]
[Applause]
I am the night everybody is Charlie
surprise surprise we have some awesome
Batman news everyone's desperately in
need of some good news this morning
so I have the best possible news you
wanted Batman in the arrowverse we
finally got him
but not just any Batman one of the best
Batman of all time so we'll break it
down and because this is such awesome
news we'll do a new giveaway for the
Batman Beyond special edition blu-ray
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your best batman
crisis on Infinite Earths theory on the
video so if you didn't see the news this
morning the reason why everyone is
freaking out in a good way is because
they're doing the TCAs panel for the CW
shows they announced that they're going
to have batman during crisis on Infinite
Earths crossover but get this it gets
even better the batman that they're
going to be using is kevin conroy
probably one of the best Batman of all
time but he'll be playing a live-action
version of Batman finally we finally hit
live-action Kevin Conroy unless you're a
really little kid you probably remember
him from Batman the Animated Series in
Batman Beyond two of the best Batman
shows of all times they also did a
couple of Batman animated movies with
Kevin Conroy mask of the phantasm is
probably one of the best Batman movies
of all time it just happens to be
animated
[Music]
[Applause]
I never would have thought they had been
able to do something like this and I
never I never expected them to get kevin
conroy to come guest-star but if they're
doing Burt Ward from the 1966 Batman TV
series they didn't say who he's playing
but I'm hoping that he's playing an
older version of Dick Grayson Robin from
some earth either from our earth one or
from some other earth in the multiverse
they didn't come right out and say Kevin
Conroy is playing the Batman Beyond
version of Batman but they say Batman
from the future which i think is code
for Batman Beyond I think that they're
trying to save what his costume is going
to look like and all the stuff he'll be
talking about but it almost sounds like
they're trying to canonize the events of
Batman the Animated Series in the Batman
Beyond series because that's basically a
sequel to Batman the Animated Series to
the air overs the same way that they did
with John Wesley ships 90s flash TV
series the bummer about that is that the
monitor basically erased everyone from
that multiverse because he was testing
them to see if they were the ones that
would help him defend the rest of the
multiverse against the anti-monitor if
you don't remember why our good version
of the monitor was going around erasing
universes in the multiverse that's
because he was looking for people that
were strong enough to stand with him
against the coming of the anti-monitor
so if a universe of heroes was deemed
unworthy he just erased them which seems
kind of hardcore because that's
basically what the anti-monitor is gonna
be doing during crisis on Infinite
Earths but you have to imagine that if
say like Michael Keaton showed up during
the crossover they would say that he's
from Earth 89 because of his 1989 Batman
movie you see how they weave in all
those big Easter eggs so they're trying
to canonize as many cool things as they
can to the arrowverse like saying oh wow
the events of Batman the Animated Series
took place within the arrowverse but the
thing about earth one's version of
Batman is that they claimed that he
disappeared without a trace a couple
years before last year's crossover Bruce
Wayne got us out of jail
doesn't sound like him no I wasn't
waiting left Gotham three years ago why
to go where
no one knows
I was weighing in the shop now
during a panel last year when they were
talking about the Batwoman show the CW
president said that they would never be
able to do Batman on the Batwoman TV
show so I'm guessing the Kevin Conroy is
Batman is going to be from a different
earth in the multiverse it'll be a
one-off appearance and they'll either
save his universe or they'll erase it in
the lost version of Batman on earth one
will continue to stay lost we won't
really find out who he is there were a
lot of Adam West Easter eggs when they
debuted him during last year's crossover
so they made it seem like earth ones
Batman was a mixture of Christian Bale's
Batman because this all took place in
Chicago so the architecture looks like
it came from the Dark Knight trilogy and
he's about the right age too but there
were a lot of Adam West 1966 Batman TV
series Easter eggs so you have to kind
of mix both of those two versions of
Batman together this is such an awesome
opportunity for Kevin Conroy too he's
never played a live-action version of
Batman but he has talked about doing
live-action Batman Beyond because he is
about the right age you wouldn't know
from looking at them but if you can
believe it Michael Keaton is actually
quite a bit older than Kevin Conroy it's
just a lot easier for those actors to
play the older versions of Batman then
try to use some crazy CG to explain how
their younger versions of Batman the
mythical live-action Batman Beyond is
sort of like a unicorn in the DC movie
universe right now we always wonder if
they're ever gonna try doing something
like that I think if they could get them
to come back but now because Kevin
Conroy is gonna be playing TV Batman I
really do think that if they do a
live-action Batman Beyond movie then it
would be Michael Keaton that they would
go for like the way that Grant Gustin
isn't going to be the flash of the flash
movie when they eventually make that
there have also been rumors that Lynda
Carter is going to be playing a version
of Wonder Woman from another earth in
the multiverse but she's been on the
Supergirl TV show several times as the
President of the United States but the
character she plays on that TV show is
an alien from another earth it doesn't
have anything to do with the Wonder
Woman character they always have a
couple of Easter eggs but it sounds like
she might actually be playing real
Wonder Woman during the crisis crossover
so because of that they didn't say
whether or not they would be able to do
a Justice League from another earth to
like saying the older version of Batman
played by Kevin Conroy came from an
earth where they had a Justice League
but some of them have died
some of them have gone to do other
things there are certain things that
they just can't do in present day so
Justice League is one of those things
that you'll never see the younger
versions of the characters do but a
really cool workaround trick that they
used in last year's crossover especially
for a green lantern because they're not
allowed to do Green Lantern characters
is saying that Diggle from John Wesley
ship's 90s flash TV show earth was a
version of John Stuart Green Lantern my
name is Barry Allen hello John wearing
your rings thanks must be different here
before they announced Kevin Conroy is
Batman during the crossover the Diggle
Green Lantern twist was probably the
biggest surprise I've ever had I always
expected them to canonize the 90s Barry
Allen John Wesley Shipp within the
universe because we actually saw that
during flash season two like they flash
his costumes like oh there's probably a
Barry Allen from another earth in the
multiverse somewhere but just to be
clear because they said Kevin Conroy
is doing this during the crossover
episodes they're just talking about the
five actual crossover episodes it's
getting a little confusing because all
the first half of the season on arrow is
going to be crisis on Infinite Earths so
you have a lot of crisis stuff happening
on all the shows in the regular episodes
but then you have the actual real
crossover episodes the first three
crossover episodes are gonna air in
early December like they usually air the
crossover episodes around that time of
year they're gonna end on a cliffhanger
then the rest of the crossover the last
two episodes are gonna air in January
when all the shows come back so just
imagine the biggest possible cliffhanger
that you could imagine what are you not
telling me I've seen your future Oliver
and eggs rebel and unavoidable I have
watched you die I think they're doing
that just to try and keep as many of the
extra viewers that they're getting for
this big crossover because they're
probably gonna double or triple their
viewership because so many people have
stopped watching the shows are gonna
come back now just to see how crazy
everything gets but post all your Kevin
Conroy Batman theories and predictions
in the video do you actually think
they're gonna try and canonize the
events of Batman the Animated Series to
the air
verse so what'll happen is I'll name a
giveaway winner when I post new DC
there'll be a Titan season 2 trailer
coming sometime really soon so I'll do a
video for that as soon as it post but
leave all your requests in the comments
below click here for my Tom Welling
crisis on Infinite Earths video and
click here for all my Avengers endgame
deleted scenes videos thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight